FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S "ANGLE."THE H
FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S "ANGLE."THE U
FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S "ANGLE."THE D
FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S "ANGLE."THE A
FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S "ANGLE."THE I
FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S "ANGLE."THE G
FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S "ANGLE."THE C
FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S "ANGLE."THE O
FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S "ANGLE."THE
ATTENTION.
FIRST, MEET THE CHAIRMAN, THE
FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S "ANGLE."
>> Laura: AHAD A HORRIBLE DREAM
LAST NIGHT, WAKE UP IN A COLD
SWEAT.
THE CALENDAR READ WEDNESDAY
NOVEMBER 7 AND THE DEMOCRATS HAD
GAINED CONTROL OF THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES.
AND THE FIRST HORRIBLE VISION I
HAD, BLURRY, IT WAS MAXINE
WATERS, TALKING ABOUT JUSTICE
KAVANAUGH.
>> IT WAS HEARTBREAKING, BUT I
THINK WOMEN ARE NOT GOING TO
RECEDE, WOMEN ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO CONFRONT WHAT TOOK
PLACE IN THAT CONFIRMATION.
AND HIM.
AND HE WON'T REST EASY IN HIS
JOB.
>> Laura: OH, OH, OH, WHAT WAS
ON TO YOU, WHAT DOES THAT MEAN,
HE WON'T REST EASY?
SOUNDS LIKE AN IMPLICIT THREAT.
OR DOES SHE MEAN IMPEACHMENT?
THE JUSTICE IS GOING TO BE
CONFRONTED IN HIS HOME AND
PUBLIC LIFE, PUBLIC PLACES?
IS IT SOME KIND OF DOG WHISTLE
TO GO AFTER KAVANAUGH?
SIMILAR TO HER EARLIER CALL TO
HARASS CONSERVATIVES EARLIER
THIS YEAR?
WELL, SOON, SHE MAY BE HARASSING
ALL OF AMERICA.
IF THE DEMOCRATS REST CONTROL OF
THE -- WREST CONTROL OF THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES, AUNTIE
EM WOULD BE THE FIRST WOMAN TO
LEAD THE HOUSE SERVICES
COMMITTEE.
SHE FACED THREE ETHICS
VIOLATIONS FOR SETTING UP A
MEETING BETWEEN TREASURY
OFFICIALS AND A GANK HER HUSBAND
SAT ON THE BOARD OF.
SHE THINKS SHE'S TEFLON.
SHE KEEPS ON MAKING THREATS.
>> I'M GOING TO KEEP SAYING THAT
WE NEED TO IMPEACH HIM.
JOIN WITH ME, LET'S IMPEACH 45!
IF HE THINKS HE CAN STOP ME,
FROM TALKING ABOUT IMPEACHING
45, HE HAS ANOTHER THOUGHT
COMING.
IMPEACH 45!
>> Laura: IN A'S MY RING TONE BY
THE WAY.
I ALWAYS WANT TO AVOID IT.
AND THIS IS ANOTHER MAN WHO
SHARES MAXINE'S IMPEACHMENT
FANTASY.
IF THE DEMOCRATS SWEEP TO POWER,
JERRY NADLER WOULD BECOME
CHAIRMAN OF THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
SHARMNING HIS LIFE -- FORK AND
KNIFE -- FOR KAVANAUGH.
>> WE WOULD HAVE TO INVESTIGATE
ANY CREDIBLE ALLEGATIONS OF
PERJURY AND OTHER THINGS THAT
HAVEN'T BEEN PROPERLY LOOKED
INTO BEFORE.
IF HE IS ON THE SUPREME COURT,
AND THE SENATE HASN'T
INVESTIGATED, THEN THE HOUSE
WILL HAVE TO.
>> Laura: NOW, WITH ALL THAT'S
FACING AMERICA, ALL OF THE
POTENTIAL, DO WE WANT A
PROLONGED INQUISITION OF A
SITTING SUPREME COURT JUSTICE?
THE LAST AND ONLY TIME A HOUSE
IMPEACHED A SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE, 1804.
SO, READY FOR KAVANAUGH'S CIRCUS
PART 3?
OR UNLESS SENATOR SPARTACUS
BECOMES A LION TAMER I'M GOING
TO PASS.
MASSACHUSETTS CONGRESSMAN RICHIE
NEIL.
HE'S POISED TO BECOME THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE HOUSE WAYS AND
MEANS COMMITTEE.
IF THAT HAPPENS, FORGET THE IDEA
OF MAKING THOSE TRUMP MIDDLE
CLASS TAX CUTS PERMANENT.
NEIL WAS A FIERCE OPPONENT OF
THE TRUMP TAX PACKAGE AND IS
EXPECTED TO TRY TO ROLL BACK
SOME OF THOSE TAX CUTS.
THERE GOES OUR ECONOMIC BOON.
THEN THERE'S MARYLAND'S ELIJAH
CUMMINGS.
HE'S IN LINE TO BECOME CHAIRMAN
OF THE OVERSIGHT AND GOVERNMENT
REFORM COMMIT.
HIS MISSION, TO INVESTIGATE THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION 7 WAYS TO
SUNDAY.
>> I WANT TO LOOK AT WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS DONE, AIDED
AND ABETTED, BY THE REPUBLICANS
IN CONGRESS, TO TEAR DOWN THE
FOUNDATIONS OF OUR DEMOCRACY.
>> Laura: THAT'S ALL.
CUMMINGS IS ALREADY ON RECORD AS
SAYING HE'D LIKE TO PROBE
TRUMP'S CANCELLATION OF SECURITY
CLEARANCES, THE 2020 CENSUS, THE
RIGHTS OF FEDERAL EMPLOYEES, AND
THE PRESIDENT'S TREATMENT OF THE
PRESS.
NOW, THIS FRIVOLOUS PARTISAN
INVESTIGATIONS WOULD COST
MILLIONS AND ACHIEVE ZIPPO.
THEY WOULD SERVE THE DEMOCRATS'
GOAL OF PARALYZING THE PRESIDENT
AND HIS ADMINISTRATION IN A
BLIZZARD OF PROBES AND
INQUIRIYIES.
MY FRIENDS IT WON'T END THERE.
IF PETER DEFAZIO BECOMES THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN HE'S MANNING TO DO
OVERSIGHT OF THE TRUMP
INTERNATIONAL HOTEL AND THE
GOVERNMENT SERVICES
ADMINISTRATION.
WHICH IS THE AGENCY THAT GAVE
TRUMP A LEASE FOR THE OLD POINT
OFFICE BUILDING IN D.C. WHERE
THE HOTEL IS.
AND IF MONEY IS POWER,
CONGRESSWOMAN NITA LOWEY IS
ABOUT TO BECOME THE QUEEN OF THE
HOUSE.
SHE COULD HEADED POWERFUL
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE IN
CHARGE OF SPENDING YOUR MONEY.
LOWEY HAS NEVER MET A LIBERAL
SOCIAL PROGRAM SHE DIDN'T LIKE.
THE 81-YEAR-OLD DEMOCRAT WOULD
HAVE THE POWER TO SHIFT OUR
SPENDING PRIORITIES FROM THINGS
LIKE DEFENSE, BORDER SECURITY,
TO WELFARE AND ARTS PROGRAMS.
THAT WILL KEEP THE ECONOMY
HUMMING.
AND THE WALL, IT'LL NEVER BE
FUNDED.
THE LEFT IS SALIVATING OVER THE
POSSIBILITIES IN A LIBERAL HOUSE
TAKEOVER.
>> ADAM SCHIFF COULD RESTART THE
RUSSIA INVESTIGATION.
ELIJAH CUMMINGS WILL HAVE
SUBPOENA POWER AT OVERSIGHT.
MAXINE WATERS WILL BE THE HEAD
OF THE COMMITTEE ON FINANCIAL
REGULATION.
THE HOUSE WAYS AND MEANS
COMMITTEE, WILL BE ABLE TO
OBTAIN TRUMP'S TAX RETURNS.
IT'S GOING TO BE A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT ENVIRONMENT IN TERMS
OF THE ABILITY TO HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE OUTRAGES.
>> Laura: THE MSNBC CROWD, IT'S
CHRISTMAS MORNING.
FOR AMERICA, IT WOULD BE THE
NIGHTMARE WE CANNOT ALLOW TO
BECOME A REALITY.
IF THIS BAND OF LIBERAL MISFITS
AND RADICALS TAKES THE REINS OF
THE POWER IN NOVEMBER, IT WILL
BE SCARIER THAN HALLOWEEN, ONLY
THE TRICK IS ON THE AMERICAN